Honestly, vital Indonesia is still considered
satanic music, so Satanic
music is black music and it's considered yes. Eh, we
're teenagers, isn't that normal,
maybe we're like that. And faster too
[Music]
[Applause]
buiten westen Indonesia
[music]
wow wow narrow
[Music]
because most of the people here only
work like farming, raising livestock,
but hopefully all of our parents
can understand that music is not
good for twisting sinners World information
to each
time with me to be Indonesian
first First the
twicsy.com the beach Camp
Hi, so because  Feby is made up of
people with different types of music, the pause is
Hip metal tank, it's a mix
of hip hop metal and Funky
Corporal cover for the usual black hijab
and now I'm
wearing the same genre of music I'm
metal trash metal,
there are several media that
see the lobby as something
unique maybe because the loud music is
juxtaposed with the hijab for the size
of a very country  religious maybe a
lizard reinforcing the beach Benoa
we have also been quick to
terrorize people around like me
once stoned by someone and got hit on the
head, but if we are rich in our race
in the village, there are people who support
us in
planning for the future, but
want to focus on music, so
professional musicians who are known
internationally. What are the bands that can be
known for being consistent in their music,
and the most important thing is that they can continue to
be an inspiration
[Music]